up with the rest of the nation on
coronavirus vaccinations
right now health officials are just
struggling to get the medicine here and
then when it does get here
get it to the public bianca holman spoke
with a las vegas medical director about
the vaccination efforts
[Applause]
those that are eligible are able to
receive the covid19 vaccine through the
southern nevada health district
people are able to get their first and
second dose of either the moderna or
pfizer shot
amy levin is volunteering her time to
help the state with vaccinations
she says the process is improving and
running smoother than a week ago
now that patients are getting the second
dose she encourages people not to worry
about potential symptoms that may arise
we've been recommending that you take
tylenol as long as you don't have any
liver disease after if you do have
those symptoms body aches chills people
have been getting extreme fatigue
for 24 to 48 hours after that second
dose
nothing to be alarmed about unless you
have any trouble breathing or
chest pain or significant nausea
vomiting those things are pretty
uncommon
medical staff say it takes about two
weeks after the second vaccination to be
immune to cobit
patients should keep their immunization
card as proof
just in case it's needed for travel
bianca holman
8 news now a special three-day
vaccination clinic opens tomorrow here
in the valley
it is inside the chuck minker sports
complex near stewart and mojave
people 70 and older and people who are
utility workers can take part
appointments are required another site
opens up this week at desert pines high
school
vaccines given out starting tomorrow at
nine o'clock in the morning
we have information on making an
appointment there at eightnewsnow.com
if you need help making or canceling an
appointment the health district has
opened up two phone
lines to answer your questions you see
the numbers on your screen four five
five zero six
nine six and seven five nine nineteen
hundred you get all your questions
answered
between eight and five seven days a week